hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video habe gestern ein video hochgeladen
wo ich euch komische angewohnheiten von
mir gezeigt habe ja also ich sage es
stimmt und darunter kamen ultra viele
kommentare und deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht ich reagiere mal auf ein paar
beantworten partygaming höchst kamen bei
sekunde 6 lachst du dir ein baldiger
bruder wie heißt du john dingens kilmer
bisschen ich wenn ich lache ich lacht
also wir gucken uns die szene machen ich
guck mal ob ich darf ihnen bei sprache
vielleicht hat er recht wer hasst auch
den geruch von rauch lieber mister
corman du hast 532 likes auf diesem
kommentar das denke ich denke mal das
sehr sehr viele leute auf den geruch von
rauch hassen ich will mich jetzt gar
nicht zu weit aus dem fenster lehnen
aber ich finde dass der beruf wenn
jemand pfeife rauchen also dieses ding
was dieses ich glaube jeder weiß was der
pfeife ist den geruch davon finde ich
noch akzeptabel und den geruch von
shisha rauchen finde ich auch noch
akzeptabel also die beiden sachen finde
ich jetzt gar nicht so abscheulich wie
einfach wenn die zigarettenrauch und es
riecht nicht gut ist einfach nur
widerlich finde ich glaube du hättest
einen kommentar anders formulieren
sollen und zwar irgendwie sowas die ich
finde ich mag den geruch von rauch weil
dann hättest du glaub ich nicht so viele
likes bekomme ich glaube jeder hasst ihn
wie den geruch von rauch spiel bitte
wieder sims 4 liebe lucy du hast 755
likes auf deinen kommentar deswegen sehe
ich ja das ist sehr viele leute von euch
wohl rainiers volllast man leichter und
schreibt man in die kommentare sind also
dann sehe ich ob es viele wollen
jemanden kleiner ausschnitt als ich
schon mal sims auf einem kanal früher
gespielt habe hähnchenflügel t ich werde
nicht mehr sagen halt voll viele
weibliche zuschauer wenn sie mich auf
der straße treffen oder bei den video
der ist und so immer mal wieder
es ist das einzige projekt was die
irgendwie beiden wir gucken ist das eine
feste freude das dorf die ihn also
lediglich frings das kommt dem geist her
gelaufen aber lasst euch von dem ich
irritiert was geht
wie fange ich da an nein es ist nicht
meine feste freundin ich finde es gibt
bei beziehungen von youtube an so drei
verschiedene ebenen die einfach von der
klassik rassig kite die so immer krasser
werden wenn man sich auf eine höhere
ebene bewegt sage ich mal diese drei
ebenen sind nicht irgendein buch
festgehalten das ist nur wie ich selber
da so meine ansicht auf läge also ebene
eins ist einfach okay der hat es in der
beziehung und hält die freundin oder den
freund aber komplett aus dem youtube
leben kehren sagt die ganze zeit eher
single und keine ahnung was ebene 2 ist
dass der youtuber auch eine freundin hat
71 sie allerdings nicht komplett aus
seinem kontinent sein videos raushält
sondern das ist auch jeder zuschauer
weiß dass eine freundin hat er jetzt
aber nicht ultra viele videos mit ihr
aufnimmt und immer mit ihr unterwegs ist
bei öffentlichen events und ebene 3 und
das in ca 99,9 prozent der youtuber die
ihr kennt die in einer beziehung sind
dass sie mit ihrem partner auf videos
aufnehmen und pos hochladen bei
instagram bilder posten so was alles und
das ist halt diese krasseste ebene
versteht mich da bitte nicht falsch ich
verurteile überhaupt hätte ich in
irgendeiner von diesen drei ebenen
befindet eben eins kann ich komplett
nachvollziehen von wegen okay wer seine
privatsphäre haben wir die freundin
irgendwie von hate verhalten von fans
und so ebene 2 kann ich nachvollziehen
dass es auch bei youtube an so die es
einfach nicht mehr hinkriegen eine
person aus deinem leben raus zu halten
zum beispiel mal komplett anders justin
bieber mit dieser ein mit einem mädel da
zusammen hat wirklich mit ihr überhaupt
nichts gemacht hochgeladen
aber trotzdem muss es halt jeder wegen
paparazzis und so und ebene 3 perfektes
beispiel sind eigentlich video und
julian so die sind in der beziehung aber
die machen ja trotzdem mega viel content
zusammen und profitieren natürlich auch
davon nicht mal in die beiden machen
echt extrem viele views und hat ihn noch
eine menge geld aber ich wäre glaube ich
der ebene 1 typ aber back to topic das
ist einfach meine beste freundin und
deswegen kennt die mich halt auch also
die weiß eigentlich alles und nur weil
sie weiß dass ich nach dem feiern abends
vor dem schlafengehen meine sachen
aufhänge so als er nicht leicht dass wir
zusammen sind nur weil sie bei mir pence
also versteht ihr das irgendwie eine
freundschaft zwischen jungen mädchen
kann meiner meinung nach genauso gut
stattfinden wie eine freundschaft
zwischen gleichgeschlechtlichen ich
glaube ihr wisst worauf ich hinauswill
es ist nicht mal eine feste freundin
aber es ist eine sehr gute freundin und
freunde bitte lasst auf diese kommentare
von wegen hayes ist deine freundin ist
der in einer beziehung ich werde es euch
nicht sagen wie vorhin schon gesagt ich
bin ebene 1 typ also wenn ich eine
freundin hätte ich würde die komplett
raushalten aus allem was ich ins
internet stelle als ob das nur seine
freundin ist wenn sie weiter ins bett
geht und alles mögliche 100pro wohnen
die zusammen heftig die enthüllung das
ist der letzte kommentar zu dem thema es
kam so ca 99 prozent der kommentare
waren eigentlich sorgt dass meine
freundin war aber wie vorhin schon
gesagt nur weil die beim web and als es
nicht gleich dass wir in einer beziehung
sind versteht ihr das und wir wohnen
auch nicht zusammen also ich wurde
wirklich alleine ich bis ich mit ihnen
einer person zusammen ziehen muss auf
einiges passieren aber wir machen weiter
ich nehme mein handy auch im aus global
über sagt luca war du hast 530 leicht
auf deinen kommentar
das heißt auch dass dir wirklich sehr
viele leute zu stimmen und ich glaube
auch hier müsste der kommentar heißen
ich nehme mein handy nicht mit aufs klo
weil das sind denke ich viel weniger
leute wie ich kann irgendwie nicht ohne
handy auf dem klo sein so wenn ich auf
dem klo binden ist nicht die erste
bewegung irgendwie zum klopapier zu
greifen oder was fertig zu machen
sondern halt wirklich ans handy zu gehen
die netzwerke checken mails abrufen
das video beginnt bei sekunde 0 dank mir
später korrekte ja was würden wir ohne
dich machen mann da vorne ist übrigens
die tür falls du dich vermissen willst
jetzt mal im ernst welche hunde söhne
leichten eigentlich die
ismaik und du bist millionär kommentare
bitte versucht nachzudenken das ist
genau meine reden es gibt mittlerweile
auf youtube sowas von fucking viele
kommentare die so in die richtung gehen
like ge wird millionär ignorieren du
stirbst abonnieren du bekommst ein keks
warum like tier so war es freunde denkt
na also ich will nicht sagen beleidigt
solche leute aber was da die die
zerstören meine kommentare ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass die dann in die 10
e mail adressen mit 10 21 verbunden
haben und sich selber auf indizien likes
hof bringen so dass der kommentar in die
angezeigte oder dass sie direkt 600 bots
gekauft haben die einfach den kommentar
licon weil ich verstehe nicht welcher
normale mensch wirklich sowas vielleicht
also ich kann hier komplett recht geben
bei deinen kommentaren mistet aus die
heiße glaube ich kostenlos phuket für
pokémon blickt auf diesen hashtag um bis
zu erfahren 301 likes hier ist die
thüringer kommen wir jetzt auch schon
zum letzten kommentaren meine damen und
herren 49 kommentare ich nehme ein handy
auch mit aufs klo andere 90 prozent ist
dass seine freundin nur zwei prozent
normale kommentare ich finde dieser
kommentar schließt das heutige video
eigentlich recht gut ab und zwar genau
so sei die kommentare sektion ob
wirklich auch der hauptgrund warum ich
dieses video wirklich aufnehmen wollte
warum das mal klarzustellen dass es
nicht meine freundin war weil da ja
übels viel drunter diskutiert wurde und
es kamen jetzt auch viele kommentare an
die einfach so unmenschlich viele likes
hatten teilweise so 750 likes oder so
auf einem kommentar deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht heute am sonntag ist schönes
wetter draußen
ich suche einfach schnell kommentare
raus und reagiert darauf und beantwortet
ein paar offenstehende fragen wenn euch
das gefallen dann würde ich mich über
ein live freuen ihr seht hier oben einen
smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
klicken team einen kanal abonnieren wäre
auf jeden fall mega chillig und hier
unten findet ihr
einen sims 4 gameplay part von mir
eingeblendet also wenn ihr habe ich ja
schon gesagt sind wir noch mal haben
wollt lassen leid bei diesem video da
umschreibt sims in die kommentare
dann sehen wir vielleicht ein bisschen
ins video wieder